hey guys I'm Peter here with BuzzFeed
here to answer all of your burning
questions why did you originally join
the cast The Bachelorette so I'd
actually I'm 28 now and the first time I
ever tried to get on the show was I was
22 or 23 I was living in Orange County
my mom thought I should go out for an
audition they were having casting calls
in Costa Mesa and I went out did a quick
10-minute interview never heard anything
you know I just forgot about it and then
fast forward now to bekka season I
remember I put in another questionnaire
like thing online didn't hear anything
from that but fast forward a year from
there I ended up getting a call from a
producer for Hannah season and it was
funny on the same week another producer
actually DM me on Instagram and I
thought they were related they weren't
and so it kind of just was something
that was meant to be I guess what was
going through your head when the
champagne incident happened with Kelsey
WTF legit had no idea what was going on
I remember I was sitting there with
Hannah and you know Kelsey comes up to
us and she started to you know obviously
she's visibly upset and I'm just like
trying freaking out what's going on and
we find out that Hannah Hannah
inadvertently took her bottle you know
ended up being just a mistake wasn't on
purpose and I guess said cool little
things and then it then it shows but I
remember then trying to make Kelsey to
feel better when we went eventually to
go have our conversation and then the
champagne exploded in her face I took
the rest of the champagne I poured all
over my face and then like I remember
just like trying to make the moment a
little bit better but this is kind of a
weird thing but thank God champagne
gates in the past watching back your
season do you notice anyone's
personalities different from what was
shown to you in person I think like the
Alea stuff comes to mind right away you
know you see you know I obviously felt
very strongly for and it was tough for
me to let her go the first time I didn't
necessarily want to let her go and you
know obviously I saw I was influenced a
lot for sure from some of the women
early on about their opinions of her and
I struggled with that like how much do I
listen to them and how much do I kind of
just trust my own heart if all might you
know fall in the heart there I don't
want to see like a leia was like a
different person than when I thought she
was cuz I know that she was involved
with some drama and involved with
commerce like there was some
conversations I saw of her that I was
kind of like she really you got to go
and say
and you got to kind of spread that when
I'm literally sticking my neck out on
the line for you like no other right now
and taking all this heat
do you regret sending a lay a home or
how that entire situation played out
would you have done anything differently
yeah I do
I definitely regret sending her home
again it's tough and I you know you
could go back in time and do things
differently but you could also look at
you could say that about anything in
life so it's not just being The Bachelor
and what would you regret there's a
tough weird complicated situation for me
and I had so many people that were so
against her in the house and the whole
it was just such a toxic environment
it's like you have to make this decision
in the moment even though I dentist so
they want to make it but for the greater
good and that's honestly why I do what I
did you know do I regret that yeah I do
I'll be honest how did you feel with the
drama that took place it caused you to
cancel a cocktail parties well the only
one that caught the only bit of drama
because the one in Costa Rica I didn't I
did that on my own I just I knew what I
wanted to do and there was no reasoning
and delaying the inevitable and being on
this side of it there is a part of just
like sympathy like you don't want to
have to put someone through a cocktail
party and have a conversation with
someone that you ready know you're
sending home I just it's tough it's a
weird position to be in so but there was
the one at the pool party yeah that I
that I cancel and that just I was I was
taking so much from everyone and it was
tough and I was kind of just overwhelmed
and you know I didn't like what I was
hearing about people saying what they
were saying about Alea and I just kind
of needed to kind of just go take a deep
breath and decompress and obviously it
caused drama but it is what it is
watching your season back so far is
there anything you regret or wish you
did differently of course I wish I did
things differently you know I think
anyone going through this kind of
experience would have that but you know
I I just know and I can feel confident
in the moment I was making every
decision based on my heart and what I
thought was the right decision and it's
so easy for people to judge and make you
know all these comments on you know what
I should and shouldn't have done but I
going around like I know nothing about
what's going on except for my
interactions with everyone in that
moment I give myself a lot of self grace
for that and they don't get me to beat
myself up at all
I know I could have put my foot down a
lot more in a lot of certain certain
situations but I am also the person that
I just I love to give people the benefit
of the doubt I want to see the good of
people and it's a quality I'm proud of
myself for having but in this specific
situation definitely kind of bit me and
it is what it is what's the like
watching the show like first actually
experiencing it it's it's tough I'll be
completely honest it's very tough
there's a lot of things that I don't
know about I don't see when when we're
filming you know all I know is the
interactions I have with the women on
those one-on-one times or in a group
date and you know watch it back now a
couple these episodes and just seen
behind the scene not behind the scenes
but just you know the interactions with
everyone in the house when I'm not there
it's it's been tough to see you know a
lot of those conversations and you know
them kind of fighting with each other I
didn't like that I'm excited still
though for what's to come for everyone
watching and a lot of that kind of
cattiness drama
I think subsides a little bit and it
gets really good I like to kiss a lot of
people Jesus there's I mean can't hide
it like everyone's seen it all of
America's seen it I'm very passionate
person that will never change and you
know if I'm feeling it I show my
affection and you know it's I guess
physical touch definitely a love
language of mine for sure which do you
prefer being a contestant on The
Bachelorette or being attached that's
the easiest question ever being a
bachelor for sure oh no I I definitely I
loved being a bachelor for sure a lot
more in the Bachelorette The Bachelor it
was awesome but I never I've never had
that huge kind of personality so you
know group dates it was always a little
weird for me I didn't want to have to
try too hard to stick out so I was kind
of battle with that but being the
bachelor you know you're very lucky to
have a lot of amazing women there I'm
trying to pursue a relationship with you
as well and I don't I just felt that
role was a lot better for me than the
other one what was your first impression
of Hanabi
you know what so I remember the first
time I ever saw Hannah beam was I was
sitting in my bed and wash it hurt
season on The Bachelor with Colton and
it was their date their first one-on-one
date I remember was her birthday and so
funny fast forward a year I had a really
crazy date with her on her birthday but
that's beside the point
and I remember watching her and she got
super awkward you know with her toast
and whatnot and uncomfortable but I
remember relating to her so much because
I'm like I am always like I can be a
very shy person
and be awkward or just weird in some
moments it just if I kind of get like in
a funk or whatnot and so her kind of
freezing up in that moment I have 100%
been there and I just remember being
like I get that girl like I've been
there and had like a kind of a you know
an attraction her from the get-go right
there I guess little did I know that I
would ever date her and have this crazy
story later on full but that's that was
my first impression what has been your
favorite day on your Susan in The
Bachelor so I was actually super lucky I
got to my first date with Madison my
one-on-one was one of the most it's just
impactful just beautiful dates being
able to show that moment with my family
is such a beautiful moment and you know
very close to my family she killed it
you know she it could have been a big
big moment for someone and too big and
it wasn't for her so that was a great
memory my favorite group date is
actually in Santiago Chile we all get to
go film our own telenovela LM would the
federal you guys will see what that
means but it's a cool date that takes me
back to my roots and how I kind of
learned Spanish with my grandmother and
just meant a lot what has been the most
awkward funny or memorable moment so far
okay well so the most awkward moment for
sure was when I have to watch myself
talk about the possibility of chase rice
performing at a possible future wedding
with myself and Victoria before I ever
knew that Victoria dated chase rice that
was probably one of those cringe-worthy
moments for me watching that back I'm
like dude you look like such an idiot
right now it is what it is it's kind of
funny not a laugh about it I I kind of
it's awkward to watch me dance I don't
know why I looked so kind of weird
little some of the dance because I've
done but you know that's just me having
fun and losing in you know I'm goofy I'm
a dork so I'll own it for sure so what
was your most exciting date of your
season I was excited at my season I
would say was in Cleveland Ohio I got to
take Victoria F on a just all-around
awesome date I can enjoy I'm a huge
adrenaline junkie and got to take her
flying on Lake Erie there take her West
their two-week free to Cedar Point
just the two of us and we had the entire
Cedar Point Amusement Park rented out
just for the two of us got to pick
whatever ride we wanted to go on and
just go to it just write it as many
times
had the time of my life and then had the
most Awkward time of my life with Chase
rising here but forget that part
aside from yourself who from Hanabi
season would you have wanted to see as a
next Bachelor Dustin Dustin Kendricks
100%
he was my homie he knows what he wants
he's you know he's a very matured dude a
good dude like good to the heart dude
I'd love to see him you know have a
chance never too late so Dustin bachelor
2020 yeah there you go I guess 2021
which are the fellow suitors from Hanabi
season do you keep in touch with
obviously Dustin Tyler Dylan Devin
Garrett we were all like a group chat so
we're always kind of keeping in touch
you know whether we see each other or
not I'm just you know keep the
communication going it's kind of a cool
Brotherhood that I think we'll always
have you know for for life really what
did you learn from Hanna these season of
The Bachelorette it helped you on your
season of The Bachelor I think one thing
that I just told all the women from that
first night was to and I remember Hanna
said this her first day and I can pretty
much copied it almost word-for-word I
loved it just be so raw and so
vulnerable with me from the very
beginning and I know this is a weird
situation it's uncomfortable at times
but don't hold back at all and I know
one thing I did was I held back with
Hanna and I was probably like the last
person you know ever expressed to her I
truly felt and I always kind of like
punched myself for doing that I like I
wish I didn't and so I remember trying
to his past that kind of lesson along
right away to the women that don't make
my same mistake and I feel like the
woman probably took that a little bit
too much to heart because they let me
hear it every single second they could
hey I guess I asked for it so I can't I
can't complain before being on The
Bachelor and the Bachelorette what was
your opinion of the franchise if I've
always been a huge fan of the show the
first season ever watched was Jake
Pavelka season he was the other pilot
think about like ten years ago and I
remember watching it my freshman year at
college with all my best friends Tenley
at the time Tenley was a girl that I
wish Jake had picked was huge tummy fan
of the show and ever since then I just
have always been that romantic that I
love love and especially the show what
it stood for and just kind of giving
everyone a chance to fall along these
love stories and
live vicariously through them it's um
there's a reason that so many people
love to show what it stands for and yeah
I just have always been a fan and I'll
always be a fan what's your process when
it comes to navigating all your feelings
and relationships as the bachelor
there's no way to prepare for being a
bachelor at all you think you can come
into it and you you know you're prepared
I'm gonna do it this way that way you
just can't and you date that many women
with that many different personalities
it's it's like almost next to impossible
to do this perfectly and I didn't even
want to do it perfectly like I was I
keep saying I was I was totally okay
with making mistakes that's part of my
process like going through this I wanted
the women to know that it's okay for you
to make mistakes too and don't feel like
you've ever had to be perfect because
I'm gonna make so many and everyone's
already seeing that but you know what
it's all good what has been the hardest
part of being The Bachelor well you're
about you guys about to see I obviously
took this extremely seriously and I keep
saying that the this experience kind of
almost worked too well for me obviously
out of 30 women I'm not gonna be
insanely invested in all 30 I tried my
best to give everyone a chance but any
human being is drawn to only so many
people now when it really starts to get
real it gets really really hard for me
and to let go of relationships that I
necessarily wasn't ready to let go of
yet but I had to because the time called
for it was tough and I sucked at
breaking out I felt every emotion
literally every single emotion all the
way till the very end
that's just the type of person that I am
and I can't really change that and just
the end of it gets super real for me now
it's that was tough and that is all your
questions
[Music]